local company helping keep casino poker  chips sanitized and cleaned elite chip  care started back in March of 2018 with  the cruise ship industry in mind but  when the co bid 19 pandemic hit the  company developed something really  unique and that's what a lot of people  are concerned about they're like you  know what's what's the effects on my  chips what's the effects on my employees  handling it and if you know basically  ultrasonics are so gentle the only  danger of putting your hands in there is  if the water's too hot you'll scald your  hands or if you have a caustic chemical  in there the owner said he developed the  prototype in April the patented chip  baskets can clean more than 150,000  chips in one day the company developed a  single station chip cleaner and most of  its clients are casinos and card rooms